in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
special guest here the other half of the
sadar so but actually a third the third
of the Sarat some others you have older
brother mm-hmm thank you thank you for
remembering of course come on now that's
what good friends do that is not
seriously thank you dude yeah so one of
the three brothers of the cigar store
buns we have Peter Sardar so here a lot
of questions this [ __ ] we're
just talking about dude you can ask me
anything those things why the [ __ ] could
you go back to school how about that are
you asking me like a for-real question
no for real like it was kind of
interesting cuz you know me I hate
school I hate school with musician I
[ __ ] hate it
I don't mind learning yeah I just don't
like set curriculum right great yeah I
don't like it what somebody tells me how
I should learn yeah that's that's the
the biggest issue I have but for you you
decide to go back to school because of
that reason because you hate it
no no no because I hate it dude come on
if I hate it why would I do it yeah no
it's a because I agree with you like I'm
the type of person that's like I hated
learning a set curriculum I hated it
when people made me do things their way
and I freaking like you could even ask
my parents they were so disappointed in
me in like school cuz yeah freshman year
I got a one point oh dude you gotta try
to get a win on one point oh hey yeah
dawg yeah I still graduated okay don't
talk to me like that Dad okay at one
point out is exactly you gotta try to
get one point out I was that bad cuz I
hated it so um last year I I went
through some stuff and I realized I was
like you know what I can't keep being a
kid anymore
yeah and part of me being kid is like I
dropped out of college nothing against
people who drop out of college like I
fully support that you should go towards
what you want to do like no [ __ ] it you
idiots I am what a college team oh no so
I had a I went to UCR I went to so yo
nice boy yeah but that's the time of a
success that everybody so dude I
couldn't even get into those schools
your stupid Braille are you gonna find
it
so yes I went to UCR I had looked
trouble over there then I went over to a
Community College then after that
Community College I'm last a college
dude just saying does telling you man
like Sac State and then I was like a few
credits away from graduating and I Drive
much like three units oh what's 15 for
me and then I left and then I went to a
la dude well you know what that's a lot
of faith and you did it and you made a
dude yeah well it was a big risk my
parents don't like it no is what it is
yeah that's the same thing with the oh
she like he didn't like my parents
didn't like it cuz he got me out of
college too you know oh really yeah
oh [ __ ] oh yeah we went completely off
tangent what were the side we were
talking about uh why am i back in school
yeah yeah so I I realize I'm still I
feel like a kid in the sense that like I
never got over that mmm and so I was I
went back to school because well one I
was like I'm not a competent illustrator
and I want to be like if I'm already
gonna have free time anyways like are
you only for art yeah I'm gonna fart and
well are in psychology anyways um so I'm
like I'll just one psychologist super
fun dude it's super useful and I think
everybody should take that class you
know what I mean no but anyways um so I
went back for art and when I was there
it was super hard and I was like I don't
need to be here I already have a career
like I just need to keep going forward
in my career I just I just do what I do
I don't need this class and then
something inside me was like you don't
need this class but go ahead and keep
that attitude up you just spent 200
bucks to have that attitude waste your
time come to school do nothing and and
[ __ ] in just like pout you know you're
wasting your time and so I was like
shoot I am right I'm wasting my time I
should just go home he's Asian dad at
yourself I just have myself no but in a
way that's like I was like okay he was
right but then I realize I'm an adult
yeah I could do what I want I could go
home and all right cool I'm going home
and as I was about to go home I was like
no you know what let's just check it out
let's see what this is like
so I sat there and I listened as if I
didn't know anything and I realized I
didn't know anything cuz I've never
really done our school so I really
didn't know anything here yeah but I was
so cocky you know so cocky cuz I was
like I could draw I don't need this
class oh my god draw a circle shade here
no this is dumb yeah I could do that
with the face and now I was like oh my
gosh I didn't even know how to shade
faces correctly yeah like I make noses
wrong
you know like so being in there it
changed my experience on like what I
needed to learn and so I started to just
really get with what's your end goal for
it uh well one I think that a life
skills are really fun yeah it's it's
super useful just cuz like you're not
looking to get a degree yes I am that's
that is one of my side goals but that's
just like if I get there I'll hit that
on the way you know okay it's not like
oh I need this degree I'm there for like
I want to get better at things mm-hmm
that makes sense yeah and if the process
of it allows me to get a degree for
people to recognize me cool yeah if it
doesn't that's fine at least I had the
skills anyways yeah so you're going for
psychology and also illustration because
I know that you do art I've seen it
before
thank you and then [ __ ] sucks know
everything about you so Asian you agent
had your self esteem you know I'm proud
of my all the negative so I mean why'd
you go to psychology then I got into
psychology because I am I think it's
really important to understand how I
think because uh I've had problems like
understanding myself understanding other
people that type of stuff to the point
where like in high school I had friends
but like I never had like a really real
best friend except for like Yoshi yeah
but that's cause he's my brother you
know he had to be my best friend Oh a
lot of people don't even like their
sibling like that yeah exactly like god
bless you Oh Shi for being that way to
me like I really am like so blessed by
him mm-hmm
but um yeah it was it got to a point
where I just didn't even know like I
couldn't get dates I high school was not
a pleasant experience most of it was my
own fault yeah but uh part of it was
because I couldn't really communicate
with people so now that I'm like reading
up on psychology I can help myself
communicate with people and if some
people are hard to communicate with
hopefully I can understand and
communicate with them you know I mean
communication is hard because like like
number one you could try to understand
the human mind but like like this
intelligence versus social intelligence
are two different things right oh for
sure for sure a lot of people have
that problem with being socially
intelligent and I only started to
realize this when I got on the Internet
now you know that you see people
interact with in the comments and aside
from the comments like you see people
how people behave outside of the social
media space and in person and who they
are in their social media realm is not
anywhere near to who they are as a
person that's what intrigues me the most
that's why I like I'm studying
psychology because I want to understand
like that is an untapped domain in my
opinion the psychology of someone behind
the screen because you create a split
personality so to speak you know what I
mean and that that intrigues me but that
there's no real like I mean I'm sure I
could find some stuff if I Google II and
I find some research and stuff but I
wanna and the thing is like I can't get
there until I understand the base and
there's no point in me like learning
that stuff online well there is a point
in me learning that's a felon but in my
opinion it's more important for me to
understand the base first like um I'm a
big believer you know you're gonna make
fun of you know I'm very Asian in this
sentence but I'm very Asian in the sense
that like my parents always told me like
if you're gonna do something do it from
the bottom like my dad started his job
literally from the mail room and another
sounds dumb but like literally from the
mail room and so I'm like okay cool if I
want to do it I got a I can't jump to
the end and expect to just be the guy
who understands at all mmm I got
understand from the beginning like I got
to understand how it works slightly and
maybe it'll be boring at first but at
least in the end goal when people are
talking about that I understand the
nuances of every little thing that makes
that work that way yeah you know I mean
yeah I understand why would it be funny
for that
I'd say like you just back to school
worst nightmare indeed like going back
to school like I still had nightmares of
me waking up and being late to school
wait for ills yeah for us like I did you
were very conscientious like I woke up
like even as an adult like I'll have a
dream that I did my homework like [ __ ]
like that I did I said that because I
feel that I'm not even in school I'm
like yo what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] about
that school is just such a weird thing
because I like I said I don't like I
don't like somebody telling me how to
learn but I do appreciate school a lot
like for example if I really wanted to
understand psychology it would be great
to have a good foundation for it like if
you don't want a foundation uh hex you
can find lectures online from like UCLA
in like oh for sure I mean who wants
that sure free you don't have to pay
[ __ ] sucks
no did you have to pay though no free
it's insane a lot of people need
structure it's like there's this
education like this this loose format of
learning it's it's I find it it's
actually very hard for a lot of people I
do I find that it's very hard for a lot
of people and I agree with you on that
but I also want to add that like people
who are really intelligent my god like
I've seen children like maneuver the
internet like they're surfers and I kid
you not it's like the world wide web is
like their wave and they're like surf
and just picking things up like okay I
not do this from YouTube and I'll do
this from this and I'm like that's the
world we live in
yeah it most also cuz they're young
they're sponges exactly but there's
insane that to me that both my mind
because like I'm growing up with Kylie
who's 10 years old right now and like
she's grown up in that era and at first
my main fear was watching her grow up
was oh no oh no like this is the
generation where everybody sucked into
phones I have I can't fully control her
so she's gonna get sucked into that
world too you know and um watching her
grow up and watching her friends seeing
how they act seeing how they interact
I'm like future generation is smarter
than us
yeah like our generation is getting
stuck to these things getting like
addicted then they're not I mean depends
I mean like I said you're seeing them in
their infancy like I F like we that
every generation has thought what you
thought every time
it's just you know technology progresses
like like I said too like I mentioned
this on the podcast a million times but
everybody talks about social media
making people dumb and it's just people
have been dumb it's just now they have a
voice that's all that it is yeah but
also it's it's like um
it's it kind of great for the people who
can't who can use it the the positive
way to you know it's like some people do
use it that negative way but not
everybody does well I'm not talking
about positive our negativities I'm just
saying like it just it reveals how
stupid people oh I see I said you mean I
just there's a lot of people people a
voice they just they're not very well
thought out human beings and it comes
out in these tweets and not in so much
like obviously tweets are just emotional
rants sometimes right when you hear
people try to explain themselves and
they can't do it it's like oh [ __ ] this
is something that they develop yeah and
they didn't even think about that
that's literally they're just taking
from something and throwing if they
can't like explain it you know yeah cuz
you know like that's why I like years
ago I stopped arguing with people on
Twitter like people always ask you know
why do you just block people you don't
want to argue with them it's like why
what's the point I can't change their
mind and they're not gonna want to
listen anyway this episode of genius
brain is brought to you by bark mal
purple okay so I've been recently
listening to this one guy right I'm not
gonna say who because it's not important
but the whole point is he studies a lot
of athletes and he was saying how sleep
is like this super drug like it's like
yeah it's like everyone should be
maximizing their sleep and if you're not
getting good amounts of sleep then
you're really not repairing your body
that well so for optimal performance we
need really deep restful sleep and
purple mattress definitely helps me
achieve that oh I'm telling you purple
mattress is the best and you know why
I'm gonna give you guys a couple of
facts the purple mattress will probably
feel different than anything you've ever
experienced because it uses the brand
new material that was developed by an
actual rocket scientist it was not like
the memory foam that I'm used to because
number one I was broke and I didn't have
memory foam I had a cardboard and some
rocks so the purple mattress definitely
felt amazing once it came to my house
and I slept on it because I definitely
got a really good night's sleep
the purple material feels very unique
because it's both firm and soft at the
same time so it keeps everything
supported while still feeling really
comfortable
it's breathable so it sleeps cool so if
you're like me I sweat a lot in my sleep
so purple mattresses are very breathable
thus eliminating the puddle of sweat so
you guys will get a hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10 year
warranty free shipping and returns
yeah that's pretty amazing you're gonna
love purple and right now our listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four - eight eight the only way to
get this free pillow is a text brain -
eight four - eight eight that's B Rai n
- eight four eight eight eight message
and data rates may apply like I'll say a
point if I if I feel somebody write
something that's you know coming from a
very decent place even though it's
negative I'm like oh I bet you I could
talk to this person like for example
that's important to do - yeah there was
a there was a person who wrote a comment
because I was talking about a topic
where it you know it's about depression
and how you feel about things and
basically what I said is like there's
kind of levels to this right I I just
for me I said this is my example of how
I deal with it right I said to me not
everything is depression to me there's
sometimes it's sadness and there's
levels to this right and so when what I
tell myself is when I feel like would
you say that you feel I related to as
temporary sadness because I know that
something's gonna happen where I'm gonna
get over it so this is how I deal with
it right so how that person interpret it
was depression isn't real and I was like
man I don't know how you got that all
the [ __ ] that I said well they wanna the
thing about like internet conversations
they pick out one thing and then they
turn into like this straw man and that
they can like laugh at burn you know and
yeah you're not doing you're not helping
and to be honest it's like that's not a
good argument tactic anyways you wanna
that's not a good cook not argument
you're right that's a very good argument
tactic if you want to burn somebody down
and if you want to make somebody like
not like you yeah and really quickly and
for me too of that person suffering with
depression it also gives me empathy
because now I know they're not coming
from a level-headed place so it's like
okay yeah so I like I broke it down I
was like no this is what I meant and
this is what I said I said like for me
it feels like I can't do that to myself
because I can't
label everything is depression because
that's dangerous what to do that because
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
form yeah like that's how I deal with it
you know and I think part of it comes
from like the way that part of it is
because social media culture man because
there's a media culture like transplants
this idea to everybody the level that
you should feel is everything that's on
Instagram when you're scrolling on that
you're like that's how happy I should be
I'm not that happy I'm depressed
yeah that's not life life is full of
suffering the standard is suffering you
are you are a living life no you were a
living life that is just the truth
those things are just like the polished
things that people want you to see you
know what I mean yeah Joe and I talked
about this - not in a very short stint
but it's just people had this I feel
because I I say people hasn't liked me
when I was younger - I kept on trying to
separate life with happiness and sadness
and I thought those are two separate
things but life is both right you when
you when you tell yourself you're not
gonna go through these woes you kind of
set yourself up for failure
yeah and that's that's the hard part you
know that's the hard part waking up
knowing that you know what every day
something bad might happen and sometimes
this kind of life like you just it's
okay it's like there's no point in there
is a point I mean there's obviously a
point in stressing about those things
because as human beings we need to but
like yes something bad is gonna happen
that is that is just life you might get
hit by a meteor no that's not true
probably not meteor but like a car some
day you know yeah like that you can't
control that yeah it's just it's hard
because like I know just just in the
conversation of control yeah control
it's comfort for a lot of people right
yeah and so sometimes like I don't know
this sounds like great advice and I
don't think it is but you got to just
kind of understand the chaos and give it
to the chaos because why fight it
yeah yeah I see it as understand the
rules of the game and play the game yeah
as opposed to great way to say it yeah
cuz like a lot of people don't want to
play the game they're like well I want
to play my game and I'm like okay you
can play your game if you understand the
rules of the game you stay within the
confines of that rule yeah then go break
the game and enjoy the game of your way
exactly it's it's hard though because I
know like for you when we when we had a
conversation you said that you were like
dealing with your personal
like depression depression is stuff you
know and you did did you go through the
the steps of therapy medication holistic
approaches um I think the way that I I
did it is very very unconventional and a
lot of people might not like it because
it does involve like you know what I
always mentioned especially with these
podcasts when people listen in to this
conversation don't take this as a like a
dogmatic approach to wit the way to do
things it's just a conversation between
two people you pick and choose what you
want from it nobody's telling you how to
live your life this is just a
conversation so just continue because we
definitely ran that ran into that issue
where people will write comments and
they're like well that's not how I do I
never told you that's how you should you
listening to my conversation yeah that's
two people [ __ ] conversing and you
pick and choose what you want from it
I'm not trying to tell you whatever your
[ __ ] life you don't even gotta listen
mo you don't like you just turn it on
say like in the comments right well this
is how I would do it and I and I feel
like I would disagree because of this
but the problem that I have is when
people get angry it's like what are you
getting angry about these are two people
having a conversation we've not there's
no conclusive like idea to this it's
just more like yeah it's anecdotal this
is what I would do this is what he does
well there's no blank
there's no blanket that covers at all in
my opinion actually when it comes to a
subject as deep as depression yeah it's
hard to put like it's hard to put a lid
on it because you're like you don't know
what it is really and I don't think
people really know what it is so like my
experience with depression is just gonna
be different than probably you have
listening okay exactly you personally or
anybody listening like it's gonna be
very different but now if they do have
similarities to it they can try my
approach and maybe might work for them
yeah that's the way I see it yeah you
know okay so um how deep you want to go
with this this probably got time okay
all right close it up all right so um my
depression for me started ninth grade
right yeah because that's also when I
got the one point in school okay
the great was a result of depression
it's like a house is going through a lot
of stuff and um sometimes for me it's
hard to talk to articulate my thoughts
particularly my feelings articulate
myself
so like during that time was the hardest
time and I was like I started like
struggling with religion I started
struggling with like my grades who I am
all these things and like at that point
I was an Indonesian kid in America who
who couldn't even speak the language
really people made fun of me you know
it's like I had a I have a chest problem
people were make in front of my oldest
brother you know like so I was just like
it was hard for me to communicate I
didn't get why people were doing that
you know and so like during that time I
got really depressed but the depression
started to take on like a bad form yeah
I guess for me it's like it started to
be self-defeating it started to take on
the voice of those people who started
like fighting with me yeah yeah like it
got heavy I mean obviously I also did
some bad stuff during the time like I'm
not gonna say like I was a perfect
person and I think the thing about
depression that is so dangerous and this
is even more dangerous when people self
diagnosed people themselves a depression
in my opinion again yes may not be
scientifically true because I'm
uneducated mom but uh I think that
depression people who like claims have
want to claim to have depression and
people who are want to have depression
it's almost as if it's it like um and
for me this is definitely the case
it's me saying I don't want
responsibility I don't want to be
responsible yeah because for me it's
like yeah I'm not happy I don't
understand I don't get it why am I so
pissed off why do people want to fight
me all the time and why is it that when
I fight them back I'm the monster I'm a
freak I'm the weirdo
yeah no it's like I came from a
different culture man like I came from I
came from a place where like the rules
of society was different than here ya
know and then um when people pick on you
it's like it's just a different thing
you don't understand what you did wrong
hmm and so for me I just started to not
understand and then I cut people out you
know it's like that's one of the things
like you show up you blog because you're
like you know what nobody will
understand me anyways and then you start
to be you start to listen to that voice
in the wrong way the voice starts to
talk to you it's like you're worthless
dude you're you're terrible you see
those people they think you're weird you
have a hole in your chest that means
you're gonna die soon like I was like
terrible things and I'm sorry if it gets
dark
no keep going but like those are the
voices that I got you know and it's like
then like um I started to like really
see it in myself and then this is when
it starts
like um amorphous ooh that's a shift use
kind of becomes like a self-fulfilling
prophecy it's like you you speak your
negativity into existence and you just
you can't help but become that thing
that you keep saying to yourself
constantly that it's the truth of life
that's like why the I think the New Age
people kind of have it right not that I
have anything against New Age people and
I think they are inside of their own
beliefs but the New Age people say like
manifest your destiny I believe that is
true I truly believe that but I don't
think it works in the way that they
think it works yeah I'll talk about that
later
yeah but completely do want to touch on
that but uh so depression starts to get
the best of me and I wasn't an
attractive kid I like I couldn't even
hug girls in high school like girls
didn't want nothing to do with me you
know it's like so this is who I became
the identity of who I am and then uh
flash-forward years later I'm still
dealing with his depression but it's
like it's manageable now it's like I've
dealt with the demons to the point where
like I've shrunk his size and I've given
him a collar but now he's still there
you know it's like he's just looming
behind I'm doing my college things
didn't make him to a good college
oh I guess you go to commune college you
lose her and I'm like oh come on man
like I'm not that bad but then only the
voice kept beating me down anyways you
know and um I didn't make it to a good
school like anybody else and then I went
to communicant and I did three years and
I was like you know I'm slow it's fine
there's who I am I'm a loser I'm an
idiot I'm not smart and during the time
- I had a girlfriend who wasn't very
kind of me like she was adding on to the
depression but the thing that sex is
like it's kind of my fault - because
it's like depressed people are just
hurting and they need somebody but that
sucks because psychologically when
you're needing somebody you shouldn't be
in a relationship you know if you're
hurting and you need somebody to fulfill
you then you shouldn't be there because
you're gonna hurt other people - you
know first and you know like if that's
that positive light in your gonna latch
everything on to that person exactly and
then then your life is predicated on the
belief that this person is idolized and
then whenever that person says about you
becomes truth yeah yeah and not only
that it's like they create this like
glass floor under you that you don't
realize is fragile yeah because of our
current dating Society mm-hmm and the
dating society makes it so fragile
because like it's so easy to go hook up
with somebody and like you you share
your soul with somebody and then
they leave you they cheat on you because
they can't you know so then it's hard to
trust - so like during that time is just
the depression got even worse and then
like I'm I was starting to dance I
started to breakdance and I it was like
a half a year into it and she's just
telling me like she didn't want me doing
it and like all that stuff and then like
I wasn't even good at it Wow uh-huh see
it's still in there so yeah like I
wasn't good at it I'm gonna be honest I
wasn't good at it I wasn't gonna do
never do good when you just start though
I didn't understand I was not smart and
I was depressed you know these are the
voices that cuts up but yeah thank you
I agree to anybody who's starting like
something you let yourself be okay with
like failing because to suck you're
supposed to see if you're really good
then I don't know you're a freak that is
a that is a freak thing and you are
special in a good way yeah you know this
podcast was brought to you by fiber
my friends let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project where do you go to find the
talent how much will it cost
how can you be certain they'll deliver
well thanks to fiber finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
I have used Fiverr specifically for
graphic designs for album artwork and
let me tell you something people that
person was fantastic and let me tell you
something else
I got my stuff done on a timely manner
and let me tell you something else
the price was just right fibrous
marketplace connects businesses with
freelancers who offer hundreds of
digital services including graphic
design copywriting web programming film
editing and more so check this out take
five and check out Fiverr calm and you
will receive 10% off your first order by
using my code brain it's so easy don't
waste any more time and get the service
you deserve by going to five-0 com code
brain again that's fiverr.com code brain
fi ve RR dot-com code brain yeah
but anyways so continuing on I after so
eventually she cheat on me right mm-hmm
and I'm okay I'm cool with it now stupid
[ __ ] no no no no no she she she gave me
a blessing of feeling heartbroken and
giving me a closer look that positive
now [ __ ] that homie
no you have a bump on your [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's dead to the voice of my disagree
ability [ __ ] Luther did a voice is
stupid [ __ ] what's her name I'm so
thankful for I really am thanks a lot
Susie Kim Susie Kim actually knows how
[ __ ] that was very sweet
yeah oops yeah our ships Bell was all
good
so anyways um so she broke up with me
and it kind of fueled me to to like that
voice started coming up again it's like
you were worthless you are nothing you
are you even the girl that you barely
even wanted to be with and there's a
terrible thing is like I knew I didn't
want to be with her because I didn't
feel right with her you know they'll
continued on because I was depressed I
was latched on but anyways so that voice
kept going he's like you didn't even
really care that much about it and now
she cheated on you you loser
and I was like you know what I and then
that was what like during one of my
turning points when I was like I started
going to church I started praying and
then um it was just hard for me because
that's my my time back with God and
spirituality is a weird thing people it
really it's like I'm if you want to
believe in it you believe in if you
don't want to believe in it go study
some psychology that's like positive
rational yeah yeah you know what I mean
but anyways for me what church was for
me was it gave me a lot of hope and so
coming to church I started to see the
sermons differently and so because I was
so heartbroken the sermons opened
themselves out to me his words of wisdom
as opposed to words of of the mythology
of Jesus Christ yeah you know it's like
to me it wasn't that it wasn't that
Christ died on the scene and came back
he's like a phoenix like I know I'm
burning up saying it wasn't like that
for me it's like when I was in the
lesson I started hearing what he wanted
you know what for me is like if you want
to get a girlfriend like I started
praying at that time I was a church and
then the the sermon was about finding
your wife and like fulfilling that and
all that stuff and then I started I
started to pray and I like I God if you
are real let's see mm-hmm and I prayed
and I prayed and I was like I want a
really dope relationship and these are
the things that I want I don't want her
to cheat on me I don't want to and I
started to list all these things and
God was like well this like not God like
I didn't have like a voice I was like
beuter it wasn't like that but like
after I prayed a little voice in my head
just was like is that really what you
want and then another part of my head
was like nah I want it I want to hook up
with chicks I've never hooked up with
chicks yeah yeah you know what hey yeah
and so I had like these other voices in
my head and they're like I listen to the
one that was like no it's not that's not
what I want and I'm like is that now
what I want and then another voice came
up and is like that is what you want
that's really what you want but you've
been seeking all you've been seeking
that in like anything that comes because
you you don't get it like you don't get
those girls anyways and oh yeah okay
cool so how can I get that girl that I
want that's a quality chick you know and
so I started praying and then um I
started seeing like well I can't be
hooking up with girls like if I'm gonna
hook up with girls then that's not the
type of girl that I want I started
getting these like things of like what I
don't want and then um I started I met
Bethany yeah and then I met Bethany uh
shoot that was like a year or two after
I broke with Allison like during all
that time and she was amazing dude like
amazing like literally all the things
that like that I prayed for it but
anyways um depressions still just kind
of kept on coming so like I got with a
girl I got everything I wanted
depression kept on coming and then um I
want to skip over the whole acting part
because I think we come back to that
later when I want to cut back to it if
you want to talk about that depression
to happening but um flash-forward
depressions I reached some success in
terms of acting every success in terms
of like social media or people would say
you know what I mean yeah then I still
had depression and I was like you know
this is weird
like I thought that this was supposed to
go away when when things are good I
thought that's what how depression works
and then I looked up and I was like oh
that's how depression works it doesn't
go when things are good but then I
started thinking what I'm like do I want
depression you know so I started to be
new things I start I took school I did
all that stuff and during my process of
doing school I also decided to do
stand-up comedy like an idiot maybe
stand-up comedy is very terrifying and
it's very very hard and I wanted to
conquer that within myself and so I took
up stand-up comedy in the stupidest way
I didn't even start small someone hit me
up and was like hey do you want to do
stand-up comedy for beginners and I was
like
yeah and so he put me down on the
schedule and I couldn't back out I was
like oh very harsh oh my god myself into
so I did it so then I'm I was doing it
and then I was going to church during
the time and then I'm I was having a
moment with God I was in worship in the
singing praise and all that stuff and I
came home and I was bummed because I was
working on stand-up comedy and I
couldn't find the right thing and I was
talking to my friend who does stand-up
comedy know like what do you know the
most I was like I know depression like
because I kind of thought I did I don't
know depression I don't know anything
about depression I know my version of
depression you know yeah this which is
hilarious but people think they know
depression just cuz they know their own
version you know but anyways this is
like way coming back to it I was um I
was in the mirror trying to run my my
jokes because that's what I do when I
prep my jokes is like no I do it in the
mirror to see if I can actually like do
it with confidence to see if I even do
it can do it right what do I look like
doing it I started running my jokes and
then I stopped for a moment and then I
just started pray and I was like I am
NOT doing it right I'm not doing it
right and people aren't gonna laugh
because they know this is this isn't
this isn't feeling right you know what I
mean yeah and they're gonna see that it
doesn't feel right people people can
read your energy especially if you're on
stage what light smashed on you and
they're all looking at you they can they
can tell when you're not feeling good
you know and I mean I'm sure you know
you didn't out stand up like god dude
yeah props it's very very terrible
oh it's still terrified anyway so I was
there and then I started praying oh my
god how can I get good at this and then
a little voice again came up and he's
like talk about something something real
not just something real about something
real and I was like I looked in the
mirror I opened my eyes and I was like
all right I'm gonna talk about
depression and then right when I was
about to ride the jokes about depression
another voice came up and is like is
this really what you want to do you want
to talk about depression you want to be
the guy that's depressed do you want to
have depression and I looked at myself
in the mirror I was like do I have a
choice and then the voice was like you
have a choice now this is where is give
me a controversial because people say
there's no choice and depression and I
wholeheartedly agree when you're in
depression you can't do nothing you know
and I know hardly agree and I don't know
why this was a situation for me it's an
anomaly for myself as
I feel very blessed that I got this this
opportunity to feel this way so don't
get me wrong don't don't think that
that's the norm that if you look in the
mirror and think I don't want to be
depressed you won't be depressed that's
not out anyways for me this is how it
was I was like do I have a choice and a
little voice in my head said yes and I
said serious yeah I was like yes and I
was like I don't want to be depressed
and then suddenly I felt like God it was
like I you're not gonna be depressed
you're not gonna have anxiety anymore
but you're gonna deal you're gonna deal
with your problems you're gonna deal
with everything that you have kept
hidden and I was like what do you mean I
don't keep nothing hidden my life's on
the on the internet I tweet literally
how I feel I post literally what I feel
I even have a post of like flowers I'm
like I am real God and then um it just
kind of hit me even harder and I was
like oh my gosh I'm not real with myself
like I I have been seeing myself as Who
I have defined myself to be who people
have defined myself to be as opposed to
Who I am
to who God made me to be I know that
sounds weird but to how let's let's say
in the New Age way because I feel I
people get that better - who the
universe made me to be you know but like
um so I started at that point I just
started to just be real with myself and
I was like okay Who am I I keep you know
like people keep saying I'm a
good-looking dude but I people see this
I see all of my 28 years of life and
majority of my life I was not
good-looking but that's not who I am
anymore now like people do say I'm
good-looking so I should trust them I
should feel that way
you know and I was like okay well that
feels nice oh thank you
these people actually think that way
about me that's cool and so I started
being real with myself and I was like oh
okay that's where I fall short so this
and this and then it got to a point of
like me doing the stand-up thing and
then I was real doing the stand-up and
it actually worked
you know I people laughed at my jokes I
started exploring more and then I
decided to get baptized and during the
baptism it was it was fantastic I felt
like a new person and um it just really
helped me um repurpose myself the moment
that like it said I didn't have to be
that
I started to look at myself and I was
like all right well I'm feeling this way
for a reason you know what is that
reason why don't I feel fulfilled and
then I realized that like I pointed my
life
at what the world wanted me to point out
and and it's not the fall of the world I
feel like society nowadays the culture
of being very I guess material is just
it's just innate because that's the
culture we live in and I don't want to
blame anybody you know yeah but that got
into me so hard that I didn't even
realize that that's what I was pointing
at and I couldn't I couldn't be happy
because I needed things I needed I
needed success I needed money I needed
to have a car all these things that
people tell you on like television all
these things that people tell you got to
have these things and to a certain
extent you do have to have money because
you live in a world that is money based
you need to provide for yourself you
can't be an idiot you know but then I
didn't need that to survive because I
have enough money I'm not like balling
and money Power Rangers didn't pay us
that much like I have enough money to
survive from my family and to be okay
now and so I was like I'm very thankful
for that and then I started to
reorganize my needs and at that point
psychologically what started happening
when I when I got baptized is um I start
to reprioritize myself as opposed to
being like I wanna I need
success for me that was like worshiping
the idol of success and like money and
wealth and fame and fortune like this
that's the that's but also it's kind of
like it sucks because that's how we live
you know that's the world we live in but
um I realized I didn't need that and I
was like I don't need that so what do I
need I need food I need good people
around me I need water I need air and
like a place to live you know stuff like
that and maybe enough money to live for
the future
yeah that's the amount of money I had
and I was like do I have enough for that
am i cool I'm gonna partition that I
started to partition that so during that
time like I started to change my life
drastically I started to like look at my
finances I started looking at banking
and then I started to get that in order
and when I got that in order I felt a
little bit better about myself and I
felt less pressure and then I started to
feel less anxious about things then on
top of that I was like all right I'm not
booking why am I not booking well I
could go the standard route
say oh yeah it's because we are Asian
there's not enough jobs and I'm not you
know the industry's against me I don't
know enough people I'm not enough of a
social person I'm not booking I could go
down that route and I was like but I
don't want to go down that route so what
right am i gonna go down alright cool so
I'm gonna go down the route of like I'm
not good enough I'm not booking because
I'm not good enough so I put that on
myself but it was it was a positive
thing then I realized because I was like
oh shoot the moment I realized that it's
my fault that I wasn't booking I started
getting doing better and then I booked I
booked the show that was fantastic for
myself but like that that happened only
because I realized I was like I wasn't
doing good enough and I'm not good
enough and if I'm I get good enough then
they won't have a reason you know it's
like yeah they can they can give me the
limitations of like obviously like yeah
you're Asian you're not gonna have
enough roles for you I don't know what
else but now it's also different like
the industry is really geared towards
Asian was just fantastic and I'm so
thankful for that but like I could take
that route because that is you feel for
your for your depression depression it's
more for you you kind of got a hold of
it by taking control of the things that
you could control I started listening to
yes yes yes to what you're saying yes
but I did it by listening to it in a in
a realistic way yeah as opposed to
listening to it in in a way that lets it
control me I started listening to it in
a way that's like alright dude you're
gonna be in my head you gonna dog on me
I'm a dog back on you you're telling me
that I'm not good enough fine imma be
good enough you tell me that I'm not
good enough with my finances fine I'm
gonna take classes now look now what
what are you gonna say now well you're
not good enough in this area fine I'm
gonna do it I'd do it and then he can't
say nothing anymore yeah so now he's
quiet it's it's it's like a it's a
concept that you meant I mean I think
it's easier for you to say them for me
cuz like I I mean people people say I
have been depressed but I don't know if
I've ever have because I didn't ever
categorize it as that I just called it a
powerful thing to ya know so like I've
just you know best that I guess I was
like the one of the bigger issues that I
had with a lot of people they go know
you've been depressed you have to fall
in and I'm like I'm not you don't I
don't because like well that's how I
explain it to them was well let me just
say that if you're saying that people
deal with the depression in different
ways then maybe I'm dealing with mine by
saying it's not depression
but that's it you wouldn't you beat when
people can't get to the listeners
listening if you have diagnosed yourself
a depression or if somebody has
diagnosed with depression listen to what
David saying because you have that power
to declare it within yourself and I
laughed because I did that in it's
dangerous and I mean that seriously yeah
because if you categorize yourself as a
depression you may have three categories
that fall into depression but the moment
that you categorize yourself as
depression you start thinking in your
own mind that you have everything that
it says you don't have everything that
it says you have parts of what it says
because depression comes in different
spectrums and factors you know yeah
but in the moment that you take it on as
a depression then it becomes the loop of
I can't get out of this [ __ ] without
drugs because I'm depressed
yeah that's unhealthy yeah I just get
scared sometimes because you know I
don't have kids yet but I just don't
want everybody to always think that a
pill will fix something or that or these
problems are so I'm not anti medication
well sure I don't think anybody is like
there they're very scientific and
conclusive studies that you know some
people do need medication I yeah and if
you and you're about to kill yourself
dude okay if you're about to kill
yourself take the medication take the
medication so somebody can help you know
you know what I mean
I think like for me like I just it's
weird because the the response that
sometimes I get like I said it's not
subject like tough on a lot because I
feel like I haven't been through it so I
don't really feel like I'm an authority
on it yeah but I don't think anybody
that yes if you're like a psychologist
yeah like oh like the same reason why
people get angry at maybe somebody like
me who says well I I don't know what it
feels like or if I say there's like
different levels to it are the same
reasons why they it's like their
argument it's the same thing it's the
reason why they're angry at me I'm like
I'm telling you like I feel like there
are levels to it but you can't sit there
and keep telling me that I should be
depressed that I and what I'm going
through anybody tell you should be
depressed like well you tell them right
back to their face that no yeah I don't
know what what you want me to say that
it'll make you feel better do you want
me to say that what I was going through
is depression would that make you feel
better but it doesn't make me further so
I can't do that that's why I think it's
like an in it's not a you wanna it's a
little like a get a jail free card for
feeling that responsibility because but
this is not to
for everyone for me that's how it was
for me yeah like from me saying
depression was a get-out-of-jail-free
card because it's like I'm so sad I'm so
sad people like yo hey man you can make
your life better if you want to make it
better
no I can't because the hard part about
your story is that a lot of people might
come back to you and say you know well
you were never depressed then it's a
completely different thing exactly
that's why now I tell people like when
people ask have you ever been depressed
I'm like no I've I have felt depressed I
have felt depressed but I was not
depressed
yeah and ironically dude at the moment
out there like that happened and I was
like I prayed to God and guy was like
then you don't you don't have depression
or you don't have anxiety is gone the
person who first told me that I know you
still have him it's never gonna go away
was a pastor oh really yes crazy I was
talking to him and he was like yo man um
I had some divine moment with God and
and he took away my depression and then
he looked at me and he was like no it's
not gone it's never gonna be gone and I
looked at him and I was like really yeah
and so I kind of got sad and depressed
during that time I got sad and depressed
I was depressed I was feeling like
depressed yeah during that time and I
started to beat myself up and this was I
want to say today's May right do you
know June July June we're in June yeah
so about five months ago this is when it
happened
and I met with him and he was like nah
you still had depression and then for
like two weeks I started feeling
depressed hmm and then I beat myself up
and then my buddy
I'll say his name because he's a dope
dude and I hope he doesn't mind but
James Tang he checked up on me and he's
like hey man what's going on I just felt
like I just yeah is everything okay and
I was like actually um I'm feeling
pretty bummed because I thought I was
not depressed anymore yeah and now I
just spent two weeks in depression I
feel really bad about myself and then he
was like well you gotta let yourself
feel sad you can't beat yourself up from
feeling sad you know if you fall back in
the depression
you just got to realize okay well do I
want to stay in here and if I if you
can't then just stay in there for a
while I'll say okay except it figure out
why you're feeling that way and I was
like I've never thought of it like that
yeah and so I sat there and I thought
about was like I'm feeling sad because
he said that and then I couldn't get
over my depression and so I just
struggled with not being able to get
over my depression which frustrated me
which created more depression
yeah perspective is a is a huge
it's hard for a lot of people because
sometimes when people hurt and then you
tell them a story like this the the
immediate response is to be defensive
because they're in a very hurt place
right because they feel like they're in
this hole that they can't get out of and
they see somebody else who found that
light and then they want to categorize
them as oh you don't know what I'm going
through now because you're not to be
honest I don't yeah I don't know what
they're going through and that's that's
why if you are going through depression
you kind of have to talk to someone
about it and it's not it's not your
responsibility because obviously you
have every right to be entitled to your
sadness and you can feel that when you
don't have to reach out but if you reach
out you will feel better you will not
feel this pain anymore yeah and you have
to listen to people when they talk to
you about that Stefan yeah like I just
want to shout out Yoshi because having a
younger brother who is depressed it's
hard man yeah it's hard because then
like he doesn't understand when I snap
he doesn't understand what these types
of things but without him in my life I
would not I would not be here yeah I
literally would not exist but even like
with that he's always taking care of me
no he's a really good brother yeah I
mean I feel like you guys because I just
heard a little bit of his story when I
had your brother on here yes say good
things about me no but I mean I think
like you guys I mean the immigrant story
is pretty hard you know like it's I
think it's something that a lot of
people don't understand like for example
like I only came here when I was like 2
3 years old so I didn't have the
spiritual a lot of youth what you did
now mind you my first language wasn't
English but you guys really kind of
speaking yeah you know and when you're
different and you stick out and then on
top of that having you know you guys are
very quirky human beings you
specifically yeah it makes it even more
difficult to connect with people you
know you know that's why I gotta say
really quick and I don't I don't mean to
like you could cut this out if you want
I don't know I want to say thank you so
much you do know like for being a friend
of me I'm seriously it's like it's not
easy it's not easy for me in my opinion
like that's why I don't have a lot of
friends in the industry because it's
hard to connect with me because I am
weird to understand like I am a corgi
dude you're right you're really right
look at the group of friends I had
they're all [ __ ] weird though that's
yeah well like me and how I've always
developed friendship
it's it's it was very different so I
never developed friendships first I mean
obviously you have to vibe and click on
certain things that's that's anybody
right that comes with romantic
relationships business relationship
personal relationships right you gotta
be you gotta be at least level yeah some
ground yeah we had that ground so after
after that it's just is this person a
good person right and I think for me
when I was younger I try to develop a
lot of friendships based on not on who
the person was but what they could do
for me yeah and that's what a lot of
kids do when they're younger right
because we want to hang out with cool
kids because we want to be a part of
that clique because of how they make us
feel on an exterior sin so for me now
when I develop friendships is do they do
we have a good foundation if that are
they a good person exact so and I was
being honest and are we being honest
with each other and that's all that it
is and I like different perspectives I
like being able to have a conversation
with somebody sometimes like if I click
with somebody I just I click and I don't
think about it I'm like is what it is
and I just you know that's why I like
when you and your brother both got that
parents thing I congratulated both you
it was an amazing thing to see and when
you see your friends win and you see
them evolve it makes you want to try
better - exactly it's like that's that's
the beauty of friendship I feel like
this is okay there's gonna get weird and
D&D ish because I've been working with
dandy a lot huh but this is the magic of
friendship like when you meet somebody
that becomes your soul friend
I don't mean saw as an Sol yeah like
alone I mean like Sol Sol yeah and you
can mean this in a spiritual way in a
hip-hop way you know like soul brothers
you know like I feel like when you make
good friends and you are soul brothers
everything that's on them suddenly is
linked to you yeah and that's like the
beauty of it it's like if you if
somebody were to come in here and like
congratulate you about something you did
I would feel the same happiness for you
like heck yeah good job David because
you're my soul brother but if also if
you're going through hardship I would
feel it too it's like dang that sucks
that's why I don't get Hollywood
sometimes and I feel like Hollywood is
like it's the opposite in that sense
it's like all of your feeling good we
got to bring you down a peg yeah what
really why no no no that's not how it
works in my world in my world is like my
homies my tribe my people when they're
feeling good I'm gonna lift them up yeah
if they're feeling sad I'm gonna get
down there with them I'm gonna sit with
them I may not I may not be able to lift
them up and that's okay and that's the
problem that I had in the path
like I used to sit down with people and
I try to lift them up and and people
don't want to be lifted up sometimes and
then then I get stuck down there with
them you know yeah I mean acting is such
a weird space just because like it's you
know there's things beyond acting that's
out of your control to why you won't
even book why people don't like you and
it's just that's why it like you did
like you just focused on your craft and
you had to do with you how to do that's
within your control
no I mean I'm also not like a super
prolific actor like hey man job was like
begging like January that's pretty
[ __ ] good though do the job you
[ __ ] book book yeah I mean I do book
book so it wasn't like you were just
like a one-off cast member you [ __ ]
book the series regular thing so it was
pretty [ __ ] amazing man like that's
that's the show guy can by the way but
that's all good and on to that happens
to 98% of shows too by the way so
doesn't matter there's like I went
through a whole period were you know
because of the film that I did I yeah I
got mean yeah and then all these met all
these casting directors I just asked a
lot of questions and it wasn't to see if
I wanted to you know get my way into
acting I just had an opportunity to talk
to these people to see what goes on in
their head yeah and they told me how it
works they go listen man like when you
go in for an audition you have to come
in with the understanding that number
one we are looking for somebody that'll
kill this role but number two there are
people already ahead of you and there's
not what they told me but I figured out
yeah they already have somebody in mind
for this role you are the backup to the
bar if that's why you're auditioning
exactly you already the backup to the
backup of the backup you have to
understand that yeah it's like what you
were saying earlier you said um you got
it's like the whole like you got to
understand the rules of the game but
yeah right the game it's the same thing
with acting yeah you a lot of people get
into the acting industry to get pissed
cuz yeah you don't they don't understand
that rule that's a rule if you look a
job that's enix that's like an exception
to the real you know what I mean there's
it's just it doesn't happen often just
cuz you booked the show and you go to
testing or whatever there's how many
[ __ ] sitcoms do you see in X amount
of networks yeah right so actors
auditioning for like hundreds and
hundreds of shows there's only about
like ten or twenty that I'm gonna get
make it so you got to realize how small
that pool is and how you got to be you
got to be so grateful that you're if you
ever even get in that pool even if you
just auditioned you are part of it that
is that you have that isn't like it's a
it's it's a blessing that I got to you
know
when I my first year of acting the only
thing I really went out for were all
series regular roles I was like my first
year and you know I'll be it for me like
I'm not an actor Zach they're like I
just you know I just went because I
wanted to experience something that if I
terrifying right yeah first one was
terrifying second one ice-capped over I
was like really quick cuz stand-up is
way worse than that in my degree if you
if you can do stand-up you can do an
audition and if you can do an audition
you can try to do stand-up and probably
cry on stage because I miss when I'm
acting I'm doing this role for a group
of five people you know versus going up
on a stage with like 300 400 this is
five people yeah I mean yeah and I'm
okay with that
you know whether they think I'm good or
bad or whatever they don't think I'm
good for the role that's their job
that's what they're supposed to do yeah
and that's the thing it's like I
wouldn't this is this is why I've
stopped caring about book I don't know
no that's not you that is a lie
no I haven't stopped caring about
booking because obviously my career
depends on it so does my livelihood and
I enjoy it you stop beating yourself up
about it
I there you go that's good yeah yeah
I've stopped beating myself about not
booking because I realized one thing and
this came from watching myself on Power
Rangers yeah I realized I was like I'm
so fixated on booking that I'm not
fixated on my craft you know it's like
fine let's say I do booked now I go on
screen people see how bad I am you know
do I want that I mean yeah I could I
could just be I could take it and take
the money and run
you know I could be that guy because
eventually I'll book more anyways
because a lot of people won't care about
that in the casting people will be more
into the credits anyways yeah but I'm
like fine if I'm not good enough that's
a that's a service to me that's them
telling me like hey you got to practice
a little harder because we don't want to
throw you out there when you're not
ready because you will get cut up you
will get chewed up out there yeah they
don't say actually you know but like
that is kind of how it feels for me and
it's like okay you're right why am i so
stressed out about being on the front
lines right now I'm chilling like I'm
just gonna keep myself making myself
better you know yeah and so when I book
something and it's gonna be big and I
booked my big break I'm gonna deserve it
yeah you know and when I get on that
screen people are gonna look at me like
he deserve
yeah I mean that's a really great
attitude to have because I you know I
consistently read stuff and I you know I
cried about this on Twitter all the time
like there's I'm not gonna name names
but there's a lot of these [ __ ] Asian
people that oh they're always saying
this [ __ ] they're like like oh I'm not
getting this because I make no you're
not getting cuz you suck like I know you
you [ __ ] suck Zach you're the worst
actor I've ever been in my [ __ ] life
my gosh David I think I've ingrained
your voice into these people up because
and then you know people latch on to
that energy they go they're like you
know it I'm I'm not doing well because
because of my slanted eyes no you're not
doing well because you suck you're lazy
you don't work hard you don't put in the
[ __ ] foot work so like I you don't
put in the [ __ ] foundation yeah like
yes you have slanted eyes me too
yeah me too you know I had a
conversation with somebody to word they
were talking about that I'm sorry to cut
you off and heading to a segment my up
my eyes I don't have double eyelids I
just want you to know I might still have
a little bit of tape on me tonight oh I
took it off this morning I use double
eyelid tape so there's always things you
can do anyway but there's like this guy
I had a conversation with then he was
crying to me about him not booking and
you know yeah I you know cuz he was
asking me about my film stuff there's
like oh well you dig I say bro I did
[ __ ] because it came from a personal
space yeah and also to like I don't have
your type of pressure but number two
awesome let me ask you something he goes
I'll say you feel like you deserve every
single world that you've auditioned for
he goes yeah he goes I see other people
do it and they're not there they're
booking least I found think they're as
good as me I was like cool well let's
just cut that [ __ ] out right I'll say
how great about actor do you think you
are
yeah he goes I think I'm pretty decent
so so you don't think you're good yeah
I'll say I'll put it to you like this
the roles that you thought you were
great who's your favorite [ __ ] actor
and he goes I forgot what the actor was
but I charge Clooney or some [ __ ] right
I was like alright cool well I'm gonna
put you let's say I put you in a scene
side-by-side with George Clooney you
have to do two [ __ ] monologues do you
think you'll stand up to George Clooney
yes he goes now he says no I was like
cool well then go [ __ ] work on your
crap and come back and then complain
because as of right now you even know
yourself you're not that good so so
so what are you complaining about you
know like come on man like yeah some
people got roles that you think are bad
and I think they're bad too but you
can't sit there and wall in your
self-pity and then try to bring that
person down because of their success
exactly and what's the point of that
like okay let's do this is my this is my
main thinking it's like as human beings
we're tool users right yeah and thoughts
are tools so like yeah you can have that
thought process you don't think that way
if you want but what is the utility of
that tool yeah like really like you can
have that thought process or you could
be this here's another tool thought
process that you could use they are
right I am not good enough yeah then at
least you're practicing to get good
enough so if you haven't made it then
it's cuz you're not good enough but at
least you're still practicing so you're
not doing anything wrong and you will
make it eventually yes you won't be good
enough someday it's just that like I
said we talked about perspective in that
perspective is a hard thing for people
to grasp yeah but it's their choice too
it's like I don't I don't want to knock
anybody who wants to feel that way like
dude that is all you man like I that's
you like you can feel that way if you
wants we have but we have a actors
friend that was like [ __ ] mad at me
because uh well we'll talk about after
but haha yeah we won't but she got mad
at because she you know I got tired of
her cyclical complaining about other
people and their success right yeah cuz
you know she kept on bringing up how
great other people are at what they're
doing and they keep killing it but she
kept on bringing it down like but
they're not real actors like for example
Viners youtubers or whatever right now
that's that's so that's so hey no man
it's very cool and then I told her I was
like who says your art is the best type
of art you know you're acting on on this
screen even if I act on my phone that's
acting yeah it doesn't matter that
you're doing it at a bigger scale yeah
and I told her to but I mean she didn't
like it because what I told her I was
like all I said was something for Elsa
that's cool but they're booking what
about you oh I heard it so many [ __ ]
times you know and it's just like oh you
mean like you make me issues a little
irritated and I was like what I mean by
that is that why do you have to knock
somebody else's hustle for you to feel
good about yourself
yeah maybe it's not your time yet yeah
and if they are going that route and
they're killing it and they're booking
these role because of their following
well guess what they're doing the step
that you're not doing yeah so either you
[ __ ] follow
suit or you just work on your craft and
you just do what you do because you love
it yeah you know because oh my god that
resounds to me so much you do what you
do because you love it if you love it
you won't complain about it and if you
complaining about that means you don't
love it then that means you don't belong
in that place anyways don't do it yeah
so you didn't talk to me for [ __ ]
months too and I was like did like I
don't know what to tell you like what am
I supposed to do you know it's like at
this point like you can't I mean I
wouldn't have been that honest with you
know where she came to the wrong person
like I didn't like her like them they're
not even my peers right but it's just
when I see somebody just trying to
downplay somebody else's hard work
because it makes them feel better you
know why you have the [ __ ] on everybody
else to make yourself you could if she
was joking I would have laughed but she
was seriously I'm not gonna lie I do
fall into the habit because I'm a human
being
yeah I've fallen prey to doing that too
yeah I think I think we're all victims
today I'm not saying I'm [ __ ] perfect
either
yeah you know I think what I do I I
agree that like if you have the choice
to like let's maybe try to not instead
of knocking somebody else maybe looking
so inside yourself first you know yeah
and it's okay for you to want the roles
that they got it's okay for you to feel
a certain way for sure I just think like
when you're sitting here every day
complaining about somebody else's
success is where you start to just fall
into this just this hole that you're
never gonna get out of and to be honest
to me to me that's like okay those type
of people what do they always do always
hungry always hustling always grinding
right those types of people you know you
know I'm talking about I [ __ ] not
okay to be honest those types of people
I'm really I'm really really really
grateful for them because they do work
really hard and they inspire me to do
better cuz I got first I look at it oh
my god satire then then I I laugh at it
then I'm like they're right always has
always grind but then I realize no
they're not right no and that's why I
can see that they're in that pit that
they are because here's the thing that's
saying always hungry right now what's
the opposite form of hunger what the
opposite form but the other side of
hunger is that thirst right yeah so when
people say you're thirsty is that a good
thing
no so why is being hungry a good thing
because think about it this way even in
like in a caveman way again I've done a
lot of D&D so please do not judge me and
like a fantasy that's Dungeons & Dragons
people this man still plays Dungeons and
Dragons but you should try one day man
I'm gonna get you to play do you like
you know what Peter you were right this
isn't a man if I had time I probably
would okay all right anyways so in the
Dungeons and Dragons setting if you are
hungry you go out all of your roles are
disadvantaged yeah
so think about it this way you want to
go into an acting room you're always
hungry or you're auditioning and you are
hungry in a deems issues setting I'd be
like I go ahead and roll charisma role
performance but roll with disadvantage
mmm disadvantage is you roll twice and
you take the role the lower number so
that's a disadvantage that sucks I don't
think that I think you should always you
make yourself full first you make
yourself full then you go out hunting
always be satiated don't always be
hungry because if you're hungry on an
empty stomach it's gonna show yeah you
know what I mean like oh could smell
desperation that's the biggest thing
that a lot of these um so it was funny I
met its this casting director and I
don't know what these personal casting
director meetings are I don't come from
acting I come from this this this world
right and so I came and I remember when
I when I met up with one of the casting
directors after I was like hey do you
remember when she goes of course she
goes how could I forget you what do you
mean she goes you came in you kicked
down the door you came into a personal
casting meeting in flip-flops and socks
a tank top and in your shorts like I've
never ever met with an actor that that
came so casual before I mean I don't
recommend that to her like there's like
if you're green and you're brand new
don't get cocky and I wasn't for me
wasn't I see no I just walked in and she
goes like it was she confident you said
it was her to quote her she was like it
was very refreshing to see somebody that
wasn't so desperate for a role like you
just came in and you were just yourself
I even asked I had an assistant I was
like can I bring my assistant into she
wants to be a casting director one day
and I asked her to come in and she goes
I thought that was so hilarious she goes
I don't think a single actor would have
ever done that now I wasn't trying to
impress you I was just I don't know what
was going on and I thought we were just
gonna because my agent specifically said
they just want to meet you it was a
meeting yes I came up so I came up like
this vlogging
seems like whoa she goes most people
come up me immediately tried to impress
she goes you look like you didn't have a
single character well I was like well I
didn't I didn't know what was going on I
was like maybe if I did I would have but
I don't think I would have I think I
just wanna showed up like this that's
the thing it's like like I I just want
to say like if you're a beginning actor
I the reason why I say don't do that is
because then that wouldn't be you and it
wouldn't be true yet like that's just
who I am that's who you are yeah and
like in acting I think that's one the
most important thing is you gotta be
real you know what I mean and if you
come into the room and you have a
persona then how are they gonna are they
gonna hire you you aren't you can't even
really be real in the room yeah I mean
for sure in my opinion well [ __ ] man I
was already yeah no it's all good
anyways guys no that's this is perfect
anyways guys that is that wraps up this
episode the genius brain podcast man we
went over [ __ ] education and dealing
with anxiety depression and everything
else which is something that I really
didn't want to bring up in this great
that somebody who actually went through
it can go ahead and elaborate on what
they went through so remember if you're
watching this on YouTube leaving the
comments below about what you guys wants
to talk about go over current events
whatever feelings thoughts problems that
you guys want to solve for you which I
probably won't do but the entire best
yeah exactly where can they find you
Peter uh Instagram is a Peter s Adrienne
and same with my Twitter no you guys go
men well it's modify all audio platforms
if you're on iTunes give us that five
star we will catch you next time I love
you stupid smelly [ __ ] headpiece